not even the most brilliant scientists
in the Multiverse can explain what's
going on with the quantum realm but does
it matter uh not really here's
everything audiences have been
scratching their heads about in Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania
quantumania kicks off with a brief
flashback that takes place in the
quantum realm Janet is hiding out for
her safety in a place that she later
describes as subatomica she sees a ship
crash in the distance and on her way to
approach it she deftly fends off some
dangerous looking creatures but this
isn't Tank's Voyage to fetch her from
the hidden universe and Ant-Man and the
WASP which led to their reunion instead
moments later a distraught King reaches
out for help
you cannot trust him hey refresher Janet
got trapped in the quantum realm in
approximately 1987 when she turned off
her regulator and went subatomic to stop
a missile from killing thousands she put
an antenna in Scott's head during his
momentary visit to the quantum realm in
2015 and was rescued by Hank in 2018
meaning she spent about 31 years there
while the present timeline within
quantumania in which Cassie's device
sucks the pims and Langs into the
subatomic universe takes place in 2025
this flashback takes place sometime
between 1987 and 2018. probably much
closer to her arrival than her departure
after their falling out Kang had time to
conquer the native population and build
his Citadel but then again time works a
little differently for him so who knows
how long that would take generally
speaking the film's main action seems to
run concurrently with most of phase 4
which is largely set in 2025.
throughout the film Cassie alludes to
the fact that she's had to take care of
herself and has gotten pretty good at it
this isn't a reference to Scott's years
in The Slammer or his days under house
arrest when Thanos snapped his fingers
and wiped half of the population out of
existence including Hank Janet and hope
it had a profound impact on Cassie's
upbringing in the mid-credits Stinger of
Ant-Man and the WASP viewers saw that
Hank Janet and hope all disappeared into
dust as they were experimenting with a
small mobile version of their Quantum
tunnel Scott had just traveled back to
the quantum realm via that tunnel to
gather particles in an effort to heal
ghosts of her disequilibrium Scott
wasn't blipped but he might as well have
been he couldn't come back from the
subatomic world without the help of Hank
Janet and hope Manning the machine on
the other side nobody even knew he was
down there and he only re-emerged
because a rat inadvertently activated
Hank's machine regardless Cassie was
without a father for five years it's
also possible she was without a mother
and stepfather too Maggie and Jim don't
appear in Avengers end game and there's
a fan theory that the blip is the reason
why they aren't in quantumania either
and Cassie's bitterness over having had
defend for herself suggests the fan
Theory might be true
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has never
taken great pains to explain the way
science or sometimes magic or religion
Works in its version of our world the
Time Heist in Avengers end game is just
one example the whole plot goes down
smoother if the audience doesn't think
too much about it the goal isn't to
teach the audience how to travel through
time and space it's to make something
like Hank pym's technology seem
plausible by using science jargon and
creating comparisons to Tech that
already exists Here and Now on Earth
that's what quantumania does with
Cassie's invention to Scott and Janet's
dismay Hank and hope have been
encouraging the budding engineer to
Tinker around the lab she's been working
on what Hank calls a subatomic Hubble
telescope in the basement it's basically
a satellite that compiles signals from
the quantum realm into Data that can be
read as a 3D map
need a map
and then we can study and explore the
entire Quantum Realm
never even have to go trying to take
pictures of a hidden universe is one
thing but communicating is another and
Janet realizes that someone like Kang or
as it turns out Modoc could be
intercepting or even responding to
Cassie's signals that's exactly what
happens in the inciting incident of
quantumania sure it seems like if
teenage Cassie would have been able to
Fashion such a device Hank probably
would have been able to as well to
ascertain Janet's whereabouts but the
invention's true purpose isn't to map
the mini Universe it's to get the main
characters from point A to point B in
the story
the act of going subatomic looms as a
threat in the first and second Ant-Man
movies the reason being the super suits
and the pimtech they rely upon aren't
able to return the wearer to their
normal size after a certain point the
horrifying concept of Janet going
subatomic and Ant-Man flashbacks was
derived from the notion of her getting
infinitely smaller and smaller without
any means of control franchise fans know
that Hank and hope made advancements to
their research and improvements to their
suits between 2015's Ant-Man and 2018's
Ant-Man and the wasp and it can be
assumed they've continued to refine
their suits into 2025. still it's odd
that once in the quantum realm pimtech
functions exactly as it's supposed to on
Earth's surface the quantum realm is
still a pretty perilous place to be but
not because of the limitations of Hank's
gear Scott hope and Cassie all use their
suits to shrink and grow at will in
quantumania and characters use Hank's
throwable discs to make various objects
larger and smaller too it's funny to
think that when ant-man's the size of a
Kaiju in his fight against saying he's
actually only a handful of subatomic
particles tall but white doesn't getting
bigger Propel anyone from the quantum
realm this time is it possible to go sub
subatomic and would that be just as
dangerous the real answer is that Marvel
Studios wanted Ant-Man to retain his
trademark superpower in this Fantastical
new setting
I suppose the human mind just
can't comprehend the experience
who remains at his word he was the king
who defeated his counterparts so he
could restore order to the timeline that
version of the villain warned Sylvie and
Loki that if they struck him down the
power vacuum caused by his death would
be filled by a plethora of Kings even
more villainous so why are there so many
Kang variants in the first place and why
are they all so formidable Loki's Kang
explained it this way he was once a
scientist named Nathaniel Richards from
an alternate 31st Century who discovered
the Multiverse the other universes Kang
variants were making the same Discovery
at the same time at first this led only
to self-congratulation but it wasn't
long before some Kings showed their true
colors the Multiverse erupted into Kings
at war with one another as far as anyone
knows he who remains is truly dead but
before he was dispatched he told Loki
and Sylvia of a conqueror which is the
same word gentura and Janet used to
describe the Kang stuck in the quantum
realm this is long before he ever shouts
out his own name King the Conqueror is
one of the characters most iconic forms
in the comics Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania Nails his facial markings
which are depicted as scars as well as
his blue face shield and unsettling come
until he's not authoritarian demeanor
while it remains unknown if this Kang is
prime King it's clear that he's bad news
there aren't many beings in the
Multiverse capable of contending with
Kang as he nonchalantly brags to Ant-Man
he's made short work of the Avengers
before
you're an Avenger
have I killed you before
what Janet realizes that he's not some
poor stranded Voyager but instead a
banished despot when she makes contact
with the energy core bound to his mind
which Powers his ship she has a vision
of interdimensional cosmic chaos caused
by Kang in which whole timelines and
universes were destroyed so that he
could stay in power presumably he was
exiled for exactly this but who decided
and forced his sentence King the
Conqueror alludes to the fact that
others like him are responsible for his
predicament but he doesn't see himself
as a villain not unlike he who remains
this King thinks his indiscriminately
cruel rule is necessary for the survival
of the Multiverse itself and he tries to
convince Scott that he's the Lesser evil
years earlier Janet didn't believe him
and stopped cooperating with his efforts
to escape immediately the rebels led by
gentura and quas would agree they
describe a Kang who lays waste to every
civilization that stands in his way
which supports the idea that other more
benevolent Kings sent the Conqueror to
the practically inescapable Quantum
realm to try to contain this most
monstrous variant
the quantum realm is practically
inescapable so Kang is elated when Scott
pops up with his daughter Cassie
kidnapping Cassie gives King away to
restart his ship as well as something to
hang over Scott's head so he'll go
through with it it makes emotional sense
to put Scott and Cassie in this position
but that king would really need their
help strains believe especially for
those who are familiar with the
character's backstory King's human form
Nathaniel Richards comes from an
alternate 31st Century in which there
never were Dark Ages that halted
scientific and cultural progress even
before he became Kang he still possessed
vast in-depth knowledge that would have
been unimaginable in the 21st century on
Earth 616 it stands to reason that as
brilliant as Hank Pym is his Tech
couldn't hold a candle to whatever
Nathaniel would have been working on if
Scott was able to bust out of the
quantum realm with one of Hank's discs
and Cassie was able to invent a way to
communicate and map the hidden Universe
it seems highly unlikely that a being as
smart and Powerful as Kang wouldn't have
been able to solve this problem on his
own
quantumania concludes as Scott takes
stock of his almost too good to be true
life then he remembers something King
said the powerful conqueror claimed that
if he didn't break free from the quantum
realm life as Scott knows it could cease
to exist suddenly Scott finds himself
wondering if he did the right thing by
Conquering the Conqueror
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man the film cuts to Black and
whether the world was saved or doomed by
Scott's decision to defeat Kang is left
an open question this depends on which
if any Kings you choose to trust so far
he who remains seems to have been
telling the truth in Loki when he fell
the timeline did branch and more kangs
became part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe no one knows if King the
Conqueror was being honest when he
elicited Scott's help or if his warped
point of view was merely a justification
for his horrendous actions it's also
unknown if he's truly dead the first
post-credits scene makes it seem as
though news has spread of King the
conqueror's demise but what impact Scott
and Hope's actions will have on the rest
of the MCU remain to be seen
in the first post-credits scene an arena
full of Kang variants has gathered this
hearkens to a panel in The Avengers
issue number 292 where the Council of
cross-time Kings has gathered though in
quantumania this is the Council of Kings
part of a mind-bending Arc from issues
number 267-269 in which the Multiverse
permutations of can convene the group is
led by Prime Kang with the stated
purpose of pruning problem variants from
existence three kings get more attention
than the others and the identity of two
of them seems clear since Kang has the
power to Traverse time and multiverses
this otherwise normal flesh and blood
human likes to mix things up by say
becoming an Egyptian pharaoh for a while
or occupying limbo and ordering around
the timekeepers one of these Kings is
Rama Tut a variant who sent himself back
to 2960 BC and used his boundless
knowledge to rule over ancient Egypt he
eventually turns himself into a Godlike
figure and a super villain who butts
heads with konshu from Moon Knight
another is immortus a futuristic variant
a third figure doesn't bear as obvious
the resemblance to King's comic book
appearances he could be Scarlet
Centurion or iron lad a composite of
such can characters or a new variant
created for the MCU a final title card
promises that Kang will return expect to
see more of him in Phase 5 and 6 leading
up to Avengers the Kang Dynasty
King is poised to become the primary
antagonist of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe after quantumania but he made
his debut on TV so it seems only
appropriate that a quantumania end
credit scene brings a king back into
Loki's orbit setting up a likely plot
line for his returning Disney Plus show
a man not so coincidentally played by
Jonathan Majors is on a small stage
presenting a Contraption to an audience
judging from the clothes the hairstyles
and the decor this all takes place
around the turn of the century Loki
turns to show his face to the camera
followed shortly thereafter by Mobius
it's clear that they've been on the
trail of this Kang for a while though
Mobius doesn't understand why the
unassuming Gentleman on stage is such a
big deal this variant goes by the name
Victor timely he's a disguised Kang who
travels to a small town in Wisconsin in
1901 and uses his genius and inventions
to wow the locals eventually he becomes
mayor and sews the seeds for a broader
and more permanent takeover Victor
timely could very well be the villain of
Loki season 2 or perhaps the god of
Mischief turned TVA agent and his
partner may be in pursuit of multiple
Kings of which timely is merely one
either way it seems likely that the
series will pick up where this teaser
leaves off when it premieres later this
year
foreign
[Music]